[Música]
el canciller mexicano marcelo ebrard y
la coordinadora de la frontera sur de la
casa blanca robert a jacob son firmaron
un acuerdo para buscar una migración
ordenada en medio de las crecientes
presiones por la llegada de
centroamericanos en particular menores
de edad solos
jacobson advirtió que la frontera está
cerrada
la corte suprema de brasil determinó que
el ex juez sergio moro que en condenó al
ex presidente luiz inácio lula da silva
por dos casos de corrupción no fue
imparcial de esta forma el alto tribunal
cambia una decisión anterior y abre la
posibilidad de reveses la investigación
denominada la bayatt
con casi el 90% de los votos escrutados
el primer ministro israelí benyamín
netanyahu no alcanzaría la mayoría de 61
escaños necesarios en el parlamento
incluso con el apoyo de sus aliados la
participación final de estos comicios
los cuartos en menos de dos años ha sido
de 67.2 por ciento la más baja desde el
año 2003
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 cierro blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos méxico y eeuu acordaron
buscar una migración ordenada segura y
regular en medio de una creciente flujo
de centroamericanos que buscan cruzar la
frontera sur estadounidense
el canciller mexicano marcelo ebrard y
la y roberta jacobson coordinadora de la
frontera sur de la casa blanca-
encabezaron una reunión privada en
ciudad de méxico para abordar el
tránsito migratorio en particular de
menores de edad no acompañados y es que
miles de niños migrantes mexicanos y
centroamericanos caminan solos hacia la
frontera estadounidense como es el caso
de isis una niña de 7 años enviada por
su padre rumbo al norte una tarja plazas
nos cuenta esta historia
y si tiene apenas siete años y ya camina
sola en búsqueda de un mejor futuro su
padre la envió para que intentara cruzar
la frontera con eeuu tras haber viajado
durante 22 días junto a ella habían
intentado pero lo de olvidar
[Aplausos]
pero ya ahorita solo te dejo nativo a la
niña sola para que la niña sola sin
tragar su progenitor desistió y regreso
a honduras y ahora y si avanza junto a
otros migrantes que la cogieron en el
camino los niños que llegan solos tienen
más oportunidades de quedarse y ahora
isis podría convertirse en una más miles
de menores llegan sin familia a eeuu
sólo en febrero llegaron cerca de 9.500
la oposición republicana ha acusado al
gobierno de joe biden de crear una
crisis humanitaria en la frontera el
propio gobierno se encargó de dar a
conocer las imágenes de los centros de
refugio de texas donde preocupan las
condiciones de hacinamiento y la falta
de distanciamiento en plena pandemia de
kobe 19 en ese contexto representantes
de los gobiernos de estados unidos y
méjico emprendieron diálogos en un
intento de abordar y mitigar las causas
de la migración con miras a lograr un
flujo ordenado si perseveramos y
actuamos en conjunto
desde dijimos podemos lograr que estos
países y el sur de méxico tener otro
futuro
tenemos dos posibilidades que me tengan
que emigrar por pobreza por inseguridad
por desesperanza sino que quien lo
quiera hacer por opción la
administración mexicana anunció que los
diálogos continuarán informa también que
por el momento no se ha llegado a ningún
acuerdo definitivo cambiamos de tema
pero seguimos en eeuu porque en
respuesta al tiroteo ocurrido ayer en
colorado donde fueron asesinadas 10
personas el presidente joe biden pidió
al congreso tomar medidas urgentes como
la prohibición de todas las armas de
asalto para ampliar esta información
quiero saludar en este momento a nuestro
corresponsal en washington dice
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal muy buen día
hallaban dos tiroteos en menos de una
semana que hará el congreso para frenar
la venta de rifles y que pide
exactamente el presidente vayan al
respecto
además de estos dos tiroteos que se han
reportado en medios nacionales según con
control art aids en eeuu se han
reportado el 24 de marzo 104 tiroteos
masivos en el país donde han muerto 4
mil 171 personas yo bailé en además de
lamentar este reciente tiroteo en
boulder colorado donde murieron 10
personas le pidió al congreso que
apruebe dos leyes para la revisión de
antecedentes de los estadounidenses que
quieran adquirir un arma y también le
pidió al congreso que apruebe una ley
para restringir definitivamente la
compra y el uso de rifles
semiautomáticos son los rifles
precisamente ar-15 los semi automáticos
los que se han usado en los recientes
tiroteos masivos que han causado la
muerte de miles de estadounidenses joe
biden también dijo que iba a apoyar
estas medidas de ser aprobadas por el
congreso con órdenes ejecutivas llama la
atención sin embargo qué
la lista de órdenes ejecutivas que el
presidente joe biden ha tratado de
impulsar desde que llegó a la casa
franca no se incluye ninguna orden
ejecutiva dirigida al control de armas
lo que están diciendo varios analistas
acá es que a pesar de que la cámara de
representantes ya aprobó estas medidas
que sugiere yo bailé en derechos las
aprobó precisamente porque son la cámara
representantes tiene la mayoría
demócrata- pues tiene la barrera de
pasarse y de aprobarse en el senado los
analistas dicen que una vez llegue al
senado esta ley estas leyes contra el
control para para el control de armas en
eeuu se hundirá como se ha hundido los
últimos diez años en la cámara alta
estaba de gracias por información que
tengo un 7 un muy buen día nosotros
continuamos con más noticias la segunda
sala de la corte suprema de brasil
declaró que el ex juez sergio moro no
actuó con imparcialidad en un juicio en
uno de los juicios contra el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva
cuyas sentencias ya habían sido anuladas
previamente el ex presidente quien fue
el líder del izquierdista partido de los
trabajadores gana su segundo pleito
legal
de un mes lo que fortalece su posible
regreso al ruedo político para las
elecciones presidenciales del año 2022
las opiniones de los cinco jueces de la
corte se dividieron en tres a favor y
dos en contra del recurso presentado por
la defensa de lula quien alegó que moro
había tenido intereses políticos en su
decisión dado que en el año 2018 aceptó
entrar al gobierno del actual presidente
jair bolsonaro como ministro de justicia
el segundo panel reconoce la parcialidad
del ex juez sergio moro en la condena de
lula en el caso triplex por decisión
mayoritaria el colegiado entendió que
moro actuó con motivación política en la
conducción del proceso del expresidente
lula en el juzgado número 13 federal de
curitiba
vamos a israel donde el likud partido
del primer ministro benjamin netanyahu
fue el más votado de las elecciones
parlamentarias de ese país pero no
alcanzaría la mayoría necesaria para
formar un gobierno los resultados
provisionales dejan a la mina una
coalición de derecha y extrema derecha
como potencial aliado clave en netanyahu
los israelíes fueron a las urnas por
cuarta vez en dos años y podrían encarar
una quinta elección si falla la
formación de un ejecutivo de informes de
federico cuidar verena
una victoria amplia pero insuficiente
likud el partido del primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu ganó las elecciones
parlamentarias de israel pero la
formación de un gobierno aún no está
garantizada un escenario de paridad
repetido en un país que ha celebrado
cuatro elecciones en dos años netanyahu
llamó a salir de la incertidumbre el
país necesita un gobierno estable no uno
hecho jirones pasado el rechazos y
ambiciones personales y no debemos
arrastrar al estado de israel a una
nueva elección una quinta elección hay
que formar un gobierno estable ahora con
el respaldo garantizado de
ultraortodoxos y ultraconservadores un
futuro ejecutivo liderado por netanyahu
podría depender de yamina una alianza de
partidos de derecha y ultraderecha su
vida se mostró abierto a una gran
coalición derechista estoy decidido a
promover los valores de la derecha en
cualquier gobierno que se ha formado voy
a actuar bajo un solo principio lo que
es bueno para israel listo
por su parte los partidos de oposición
de ideologías diversas lograron mejores
resultados de lo esperado y el líder de
la segunda fuerza más votada asegura que
podrían formar un gobierno que le ligue
comencé los diálogos con los líderes del
bloque del cambio por supuesto
continuaremos hablando en los próximos
días vamos a esperar a los resultados
finales pero haremos todo para crear un
gobierno sano en el estado israel medina
triste
la participación en los comicios ha sido
la más baja desde 2013 una señal del
cansancio de la población ante la
inestabilidad política
los resultados definitivos no se
conocerían hasta el viernes y a partir
de entonces comenzará la lucha por
formar un gobierno
caso contrario el país podría dirigirse
a una quinta elección
egipto anunció la reapertura del tramo
histórico del canal de suez tras un
bloqueo de un portacontenedores panameño
siete remolcadores acudieron en ayuda
del buque que encalló en el canal e
impidió que otras embarcaciones
transitarán por una de las vías
fluviales más importantes del mundo
hasta que la informativa france24
contenido con nosotros con día
[Música]